every week on Google cloud labs we
discuss a different lab and go over what
you would learn when you take a lab but
what is quick labs and how can it be
helpful for you a quick lab is an online
learning environment along with a set of
instructions to walk you through a live
real-world and scenario based use case
without needing an account on GCP in a
lab you will have access to the actual
environment you want to learn about not
a simulation or demo environment you can
access the lab environment from anywhere
on the internet using a standard browser
so how do you take a lab first get
started by either creating an account or
signing in find labs by browsing the
quick labs quest or clicking on the lab
catalog and then the laptop the laptop
lets you scroll through all the
available labs read more about a lab by
clicking on the lab of your choice
the lab page opens to the lab manual
page the timer located next to the start
lab button shows the total time that
resources will be made available to take
the lab the lab will end after the timer
finishes counting down to begin a lab
click the start lab button the lab will
not start until you have selected the
start lab button and enter the
appropriate credits or token code the
cost of the lab is indicated in credits
some labs are free and require no
credits each dollar spent buys one
credit labs vary in number of credits
required when you are finished with the
lab click the end lab button and leave a
review
you notice something else in quick labs
and that is quests quick lap quests are
introductory in advanced learning paths
that consist of collection of labs
organized by technologies specific cloud
services and practical use cases
completion of the required labs that are
part of quick labs quest will earn you
badges that recognize your hands-on
experience your quick labs quest badges
will be permanent part of your quick
labs account and profile referencing
your accomplishments can be a positive
mark of distinction you're encouraged to
share your achievements on social media
for example you could do this by adding
a link on your LinkedIn profile pointing
to your badge
there are many labs on quick labs let us
know in comments below which one you're
taking and how it went
thank you for watching and whenever
you're ready to sign up we're giving you
a $300 credit for GCP just click on the
link in the description below
[Music]